on a besoin de savoir ce qui s'est passé
et c'est ça qui vous fait tenir le 9
janvier 2003 estelle mouzin disparaît
sur le chemin entre l'école et sa maison
une affaire de disparition non résolue
très médiatique
une centaine de crs une brigade
cynophile
une brigade équestre un hélicoptère est
toujours pas la moindre trace d'effets
elle l'a fait maintenant un mois que la
petite estelle mouzin a disparu depuis
2003 400 sujets télé ont traité
l'affairé estelle mouzin dont 143
l'année de sa disparition
à cette époque eric mouzin son père se
démène pour retrouver sa fille il crée
une association pour atteindre un
maximum de supports médiatiques
l'association elle est vraiment là pour
amplifier la diffusion de l'avis de
recherche si dans l'avis de recherche
il est technique c'est à dire c'est
l'avis de recherche diffusés dans les
services de police
ça n'est pas partout sur la place
publique eric mouzin retrouve les
caméras en 2006 trois ans après la
disparition de sa fille il participe à
la mise en place du dispositif alerte
enlèvement
un enfant a été enlevé il faut le
déclencher de toute façon le plus vite
possible
c'est à chaque fois une vie d'enfant qui
est en jeu l' affaire rebondit en 2008
et toutes les télés en parle
le corps d'une fillette aurait été
enseveli pendant le chantier dans
restaurant
c'est une piste extrêmement sérieuse les
moyens sont mis tous les to les toutes
les recherches ont fait ça paraît
en tout cas de nature à démontrer que
des faits criminels ont été commis les
eaux étaient en fait d'origine animale
en 2010 ce sont deux affaires très
médiatique qui se rapproche
estelle mouzin et michel fourniret un
lien avec le tueur en série pourrait
être rétablie dans les séries qui ont
été saisis au domicile de michel
fourniret
on retrouve des morceaux de lacets
blancs et des gants polaire noire des
éléments que l'avocat demande
aujourd'hui être analysées par la
justice en décembre 2010 est le scénario
se répète avec nordahl le lente et le
ravisseur et meurtrier présumé de la
petite maelys la piste est écartée en
une semaine
quinze ans après la disparition
d'estelle mouzin n'est toujours pas
résolue
[Musique]